today on the Matt Walsh show an upcoming
anti homeschooling a summit at Harvard
which we talked about a few days ago
will be moderated by professor who
believes that quote the state confers
legal Parenthood and he is not alone in
this view the anti homeschool position
is an anti parental rights position
that's why it should concern so many of
us whether you're whether you homeschool
or not it should concern you as a parent
that especially in academia this is such
a common view so we'll talk about that
also five headlines including Andrew
Cuomo's absolutely deranged defense of
the lockdown policy you got to hear this
and in our daily cancellation I must
play for you and discuss possibly the
most disturbing video footage that you
will ever see in your life and I don't
mean that as a joke it really is so you
got to stick around and see that but we
start with homeschool now we talked at
the beginning of the week about an
article in Harvard magazine advocating a
quote presumptive ban on homeschooling
for the reason that's according to the
the professor the Harvard professor
advocating it her reasons are that a lot
of Christians do it so it's bad and also
parents might abuse their kids Plus
homeschool parents are illiterate
bumpkins and that is only a slight
exaggeration of her argument only slight
but I went through and I responded to it
on Monday or Tuesday or whatever that
was so I'm not gonna repeat all of that
here also as I mentioned it you know
attacks on home schooling have ramped up
in recent weeks and so there's a reason
why we're seeing a lot of this stuff now
because millions of parents are
homeschooling for the first time because
the schools are closed and the elites
and media and academia are worried and I
think for good reason worried that home
school may become much more common and
popular after this which I think it will
so they're they're trying to head that
off at the pass by publishing articles
and reports talking about how bad and
dangerous and difficult home schooling
is so we discussed the editorial in the
Washington Post a few weeks ago arguing
that home schooling is quote setting
back an entire generation of kids kids
are being set back because their own
parents are teaching them things god
forbid if you could imagine
but here's a another example from today
before we get to the Harvard thing and
we'll get back to that but Time magazine
published an article which details the
horrors of teaching your kids at home
now it's true I'll be the first to admit
as a homeschool parent although my wife
does the vast majority of it but I I can
certainly attest that homeschooling can
be difficult and I don't doubt that many
parents are struggling with it right now
whether you are homeschooling for the
first time or not it's still difficult
thing as especially as we try to get
adjusted to all of this but there's a
reason the media chooses to focus on
this with an article like this titled I
just can't do this
some overwhelmed parents are opting to
abandon pandemic homeschooling there's a
reason we get an article like that
rather than an article with a title like
this is easier than I thought
some happy parents will opt to keep
homeschooling after the pandemic is over
we're not gonna see you not gonna see
that article with a headline like that I
even though there are many parents who
feel that way and I know that for a fact
because I've talked to them so you're
not gonna see that instead we see this
article reading from the articles us
frustration is mounting as more families
across the u.s. enter their second or
even third week of distance learning and
some overwhelmed parents say will be
their last
amid the barrage of learning apps video
meetups and email assignments that pass
as pandemic home school some frustrated
and exhausted parents are choosing to
disconnect entirely for the rest of the
academic year others are cramming all
their children's school work into the
weekend or taking days off to work there
to help their kids with a week's worth
of assignments in one day Alexandre
Nicholson whose son is in kindergarten
so and she lives in Boston said we tried
to make it work the first week we put
together a schedule what and what we
found is that forcing a child who was
that young into a fake teaching
situation is really really hard
I'd rather have him watch classic
Godzilla movies and play in the yard and
pretend to be a Jedi rather than figure
out basic math then it goes through the
the the various other parents who are
feeling the same way
Sarah Karpin d44 a mother of two middle
schoolers in Roanoke Virginia said the
reality kicked in
sweet when spring break ended and home
learning began carbon D a professor of
wildlife biology of Virginia Tech said I
wanted to get into a fetal position and
hide out now like I said it home
schooling is difficult but first of all
you know a fake teaching environment
teaching your kid at home is a fake
environment I would say it's it's not
only not a fake environment but it's the
most natural environment for a child to
learn that you could possibly have even
if you send your kid the public school I
would hope that you still are teaching
them things at home I mean I you know
I'm teacher we have official sort of
home school but then we teach the kids
things all the time outside of that just
throughout the day it's a very natural
environment but my point here is not to
castigate these mothers these overwhelm
others who were interviewed in the
article the point is about fighting
these mothers and highlighting this sort
of position or this thought process you
know why is the media focusing on this
rather than as I said talking about the
experience of many other parents who are
finding it you know difficult because it
is but are also enjoying it and finding
it fulfilling and thinking to themselves
you know maybe I'll keep doing it now
that brings us to Harvard and the effort
among Ivy League professors and others
in academia to regulate home school out
of existence if not ban it outright and
we're gonna talk about those efforts in
just a second but before we do a word
from Bambi you know especially now
during this time of economic turmoil
companies need to make sure that they
have their HR house in order you know
it's it's it's probably it's always very
important when you're running a business
but now it's probably never been more
important than it is right now because
when running a business HR issues can
absolutely kill you wrongful termination
suits minimum wage requirements labor
regulations and HR Manager salaries
aren't cheap either it
talking about an average of $75,000 a
year which for a lot of businesses small
businesses and larger businesses that
can be very difficult thing to deal with
so Bambi spelled be am bae was created
specifically for small businesses and
helping them to navigate this issue of
HR you can get a dedicated HR manager
craft HR policy and maintain your
compliance all for just $99 a month okay
so you think $75,000 a year or more
versus $99 a month you're a business
owner so you're better at math than I am
I don't need to explain - you're saving
a lot of money there your dedicated HR
manager is available by phone email or
real-time chat from onboarding
determinations they customize your
policies to fit your business and they
help you manage your employees day to
day all for just $99 a month so let
Bambi help get your free HR audit today
go to Bambi comm slash walls right now
to schedule your free HR audit that's
Bambi comm slash Walsh spelled B am
b.com slash Walsh okay so a Harvard
advocating a homeschool ban and they've
got we talked about the magazine article
they've also got this seminar coming up
this is important for us to pay
attention to because whether you
homeschool or not it should concern you
that academia is filled with people who
have a certain philosophy of parental
rights and that's what this is really
about being anti homeschool as many of
these people are explicitly so is to be
anti parental rights and this is the
worldview that many in academia have and
then they try to pass it on to your
children so good example this the the
conference coming up at Harvard it's
called homeschooling summit problems
politics and prospects for reform
there's a description from the website
we will convene leaders in education and
child welfare policy legislators and
legislative staff academics and policy
advocates to discuss child rights in an
in connection with home schooling in the
United States the focus will be on
problems of educational deprivation and
child maltreatment
that too often occur under the guise of
homeschooling in a legal environment of
minimal or no oversight experts will
lead conversations about the available
empirical evidence the current
regulatory environment proposals for
legal reform and strategies for
affecting such reform now the speakers
list
they've got speakers from from Harvard
of course Stanford Georgetown Columbia
they've got doctors and bureaucrats so
this is a summit of people from academia
the medical industry government all of
them coming together with the goal of
figuring out how to stop people from
homeschooling that's the thrust of it
one speaker in particular it really
jumps out professor James Dwyer of
William and Mary Law School now James
Dwyre is going to speak a few times of
this summit during widest times on
stages he's gonna be moderating a debate
about homeschooling and here's the
debate okay on one side of the bait will
be this guy Robert Kunzman who advocates
regulatory oversight and then on the
other side taking the stark opposite
view will be Elizabeth Bartholet who
advocates a ban on homeschooling so this
is the kind of intellectual diversity
that you get in the Ivy League
one size says one side says
homeschooling is bad let's regulate it
the other side says homeschooling is
really bad let's ban it and this will be
moderated as I said by James Dwyer if
you want to know about James Dwyre here
he is I think this tells you everything
you need to know about the guy here he
is this is from an episode of Michelle
Malkin investigates and here's a wire
giving his theory not just on
homeschooling but on Parenthood itself
listen to this the state needs to be the
ultimate guarantor of a child's
well-being there's just no alternative
to that
the reason parent-child relationships
exist is because the state confers legal
Parenthood on people through its
paternity and maternity laws that's the
state that is empowering parents to do
anything with children to take them home
to have custody and to make any kind of
decisions about that the state is the
ultimate guarantor of a child's
well-being the state confers legal
Parenthood the state allows the parent
to make decisions for their families
this I remind you is not some random
wacko I mean he is a wacko but not a
random one he is a professor at a
prestigious Law School he is advocating
a philosophy of parenthood that is
shared by many other members of academia
at these elite institutions of supposed
higher learning what should really think
about the implications of this view that
the state confers Parenthood confers
mean two means of course to grant or
bestow so the act of of conceiving
bearing birthing and raising a child
according to this view doesn't make you
a parent that's almost irrelevant to the
question the state the state grants that
label the state decides your rights as a
parent are subordinate to the interests
of the state which is to say you have no
rights really as a parent actually
parenting is a privilege like like
operating a motor vehicle on a you know
on a highway is similar to that it can
be it's a privilege not a right it can
be granted or rescinded at the pleasure
of the state for really any reason this
means that the state has a right to your
child more of a right than you do
because you have none so on this view
when you refuse to send this is this is
really the issue as far as these people
are concerned when you refuse to send
your child to public school you are
depriving the state of what rightfully
belongs to it if you've ever wondered
why some people especially people like
this take homeschooling so personally
and get so offended about it is because
they think they they look at a child as
property of the state and when you don't
send your kid to school you are stealing
property from the state that's how they
see it so there's about as stark a
philosophical difference as you're gonna
find here and this is probably the
fundamental philosophical difference or
one of them between because you have you
know you've got this view meanwhile you
have any any conservative worthy of the
name believes that the family is the
foundational institution of human
civilization it is the most basic most
important institution it is the the
institution from from which society
Springs it's the most powerful
institution and rightfully so wherever
the family goes so goes civilization
meanwhile Dwyer and his professor
friends and indeed many leftists believe
that the state is the foundational
institution and that everything Springs
from the state and everything goes back
to the state this is why I think many of
the arguments we make in defense of
homes only the arguments that I made a
defense of home schooling earlier in the
week or the arguments that you know you
would make most people make really have
no purchase with these pro banning Pro
oversight people because the arguments
to them are irrelevant now my whole
point in essence was that home schooling
can often be better for the child that's
my defense of it I think it's in in many
cases it is a better environment a
better situation for the child and I
gave my reasons for that but what Dwyer
would say if he's being honest is that
it doesn't actually matter what's better
for the child that's not the point this
is about the power of the state and the
state claiming what rightfully belongs
to it here's the problem as far as Dwyer
and his ilk see it if you have parental
rights and you are allowed to teach your
kids and raise them as you see fit then
they might not become the right sort of
people and
by the right sort of person what we mean
is the sort of person that Dwyer and
other college professors think he should
be so he's very concerned that so many
people have values and ideas and beliefs
and customs that he personally finds
objectionable this is a big problem to
him how do you solve it well you have
the state step in take control mold the
child into the right sort of person and
here's another important point to be
made here about this idea of parental
rights and I'll make that point in just
a second before I do let's check in with
policy genius you know when we when we
look back on our lives I think we may
realize that there are many things we
got wrong and we think they're so's how
did I get this so wrong now me as you
know if you listen to the show I have
never been wrong about anything so I
can't necessarily relate to this
experience now my wife would probably
disagree you know she would take a
different view and say I've been wrong
many times about things but you know
most of us are always gonna get things
wrong and that's just life but there are
also things that we can get right on the
first right like shopping for life
insurance that's where policy genius
comes in policy genius makes finding the
right life insurance a breeze in minutes
you can compare quotes from top insurers
to find the best price you could also
save fifteen hundred dollars or more a
year by using policy genius to compare
life insurance policies fifty hundred
dollars a year I think we could all use
but we could all use it use that extra
money at any time especially now once
you apply the policy genius team will
handle all the paperwork all the red
tape they're gonna take care of that
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home and auto insurance
or disability insurance they can do all
that so even if you look back on your
past failed predictions and distress
you'll never be distressed about life
insurance with policy genes in just a
few minutes you can find your best price
and apply it policy genius.com we all
get things wrong from time to time at
least we can get life insurance right
with policy genius okay well one other
quick point about this parental rights
thing it it's a it's of course and this
is the point it's not just about the
parent it's about the child and this is
also an issue of the child's rights the
child has a right to be
raised by and in the care of their
parents people who love them and have
their best interests in mind yeah that's
that's another problem with this idea
that this the state is the guarantor of
a child's rights and so on and the state
is the the primary authority over a
child the state despite what you may
hear from leftists or the way they talk
about the state the state there's no
love there okay you can't find love you
can't find care and concern and
compassion and some of the state does as
far as the state's concerned you're just
a number your manure a statistic to
actually be recognized as a human being
that requires human something that is
far more localized
human to human relationship and for a
child that requires you know the love
between a parent and a child a child has
a right to that so this is also about
the child's rights now it's true that of
course a parent's right parental rights
are not absolute if you are abusive to
your child you know if you abuse your
child physically sexually in any other
way then you will lose those rights as
well you should
but why do you lose those rights it's
it's not because you have infringed on
the rights of the states and have
damaged the property of the state so now
they can come in and reclaim their
property no it's that you have infringe
on the rights of your own child and when
you do that then you can lose your
parental rights as you should but the in
that case the state comes in out of
necessity the state's gonna come in in
that case in a situation like that and
and wrested take the child out of the
out of that situation and ideally this
is going to be very temporary
the child is not going to become a ward
of the state indefinitely in an ideal
situation this is just a temporary
measure until the child is put into a
different situation hopefully in you
know in an ideal situation given to
another family member and in the state
steps out again this is kind of a it's a
necessary evil in those cases to have
the state come in and the reason I call
it a necessary evil is because we know
the state is often very bad at this and
there are plenty of times when kids are
being abused and the state does nothing
even if it had many occasions to step in
it doesn't so it's very ineffective and
then there are other times when the
state says that a child's being abused
when in fact they're not
so it's a very ineffective method but
it's the only option we have in a case
where a child's being abused but that
again is about the child's rights it's
not about the state's rights all right
let's move on to headlines number one
this I thought was pretty remarkable
just because it's rare that you get to
hear someone who who is so wrong in so
many ways in the span of just a minute
and a half so this is really packing a
lot of wrongness in - about 90 seconds
Governor Cuomo at a press conference was
asked whether he's concerned that maybe
the cure is worse than the disease when
it comes to the corona virus because the
the collapsing the economy may take a
toll may exact a cost and human
suffering that is worse than what would
have happened had he not been locked
down that was the question just
paraphrasing it and here was his
response that cure can't be worse than
the illness itself what is your response
to that the illness is dead
what is worse than death somebody
commits suicide because they can't pay
their yeah but the illnesses may be my
death as opposed to your death you said
they said the cure is worse than the
illness the illness is death how can the
Cure be worse than the illness if the
illness is potential death
the what if the economy failing worse
than death is equal status the people
those people stuck at home no it doesn't
it doesn't equal death economic hardship
yes very bad not death
emotional stress from being locked in a
house very bad not death domestic
violence on the increase very bad not
death and not death of someone else see
that's what we have to factor into this
equation yeah it's your life do whatever
you want but you're now responsible for
my life you have a responsibility to me
it's not just about you your
responsibility to me okay since so many
so many problems here where to even
begin first of all the illness is not
death the illness does not equal death
he kept saying that the illness is death
now it's not the illness is an illness
it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't equal
death the illness could lead to death
but for the illness to equal death the
mortality rate would have to be a
hundred percent it is not as it happens
the mortality rate is significantly
under a hundred percent it's probably
under one percent it could be higher but
it could potentially be much lower we
don't exactly know so we but we do know
that around ninety nine percent of
people who can contract the virus
survive and that's relevant because
we're not talking about a death sentence
the illness does not equal death despite
what Governor Cuomo says there second he
says that nothing could be worse than
death well that's just not true
I mean that's true if you believe that
literally the only point of life is
self-preservation which would mean the
only point of life is just to continue
living to continue breathing for as long
as possible
which means that the point of life is
that effectively it has no point if the
only point of
is just to keep living for its own sake
then it has no fundamental point
whatsoever it's just this
self-perpetuating thing and there's no
reason for it to perpetuate other than
the fact that it perpetuates so no it's
to pretend that there could be couldn't
any can possibly be anything worse than
death is is obviously absurd and not
true in you know also we talked about
this on the backstage last night if you
are watching we can't pretend that
quality of life doesn't matter that
Liberty doesn't matter I mean these
things matter so this idea that we could
destroy the quality of life for millions
of people caused them great suffering we
could take away their rights and
liberties and we can do all that and
it's okay to do that if we save even one
person as long as those measures don't
themselves directly kill people and as a
result some other people do live then
automatically it's justified well that's
just not true and of course we also know
that these measures are killing people
we talked yesterday about the the UN is
warning 150 million people globally are
going to be on the brink of starvation
because of these lockdowns and the
recession and the disruption of supply
chain and everything else so these
measures are killing people probably a
lot more people than the coronavirus
would kill but even aside from that it's
just not true that well if you could
save if if if removing Liberty from
millions of people destroying you know
their livelihood taking their businesses
away their jobs away and everything if
it saves one person it's automatically
worth it no wrong it's not third he says
amazingly says that domestic violence
and economic hardship don't lead to
death I was waiting for him to say that
suicide doesn't lead to death either
this is just obviously absurd and I
don't think I need to explain why fourth
he says that going back to work is
selfish because it's not just about you
okay well what about locking down the
economy to protect certain populations
of people thereby causing other people
to lose everything and end up destitute
could the person who is losing
everything say to the people
who you know that we've lot the people
we've locked down to protect couldn't
couldn't that person say it's not just
about you it's also about me so couldn't
this logic work the other way as well so
this is simply a remarkable almost
machine gun rapid fire delivery of
falsehoods and fallacies from from Cuomo
number two on the theme of Democrats
saying insane things on video here is
this there's a lot that we could be
doing right now but ultimately
the I think when we talk about this idea
of reopening society you know only in
America does the president when the
president tweets about liberation does
he mean go back to work when we you know
have this discussion about going going
back or reopening I think a lot of
people should just say no we're not
going back to that we're not going back
to working 70 hour weeks just so that we
could put food on the table and not even
feel any sort of semblance of security
in our lives so the congresswoman who is
still working and getting paid says that
low-wage workers shouldn't go back to
work it must be nice to have that kind
of privilege where you could sit back
pontificating about economic theories
and so on suggesting that workers
shouldn't go back to work it's very very
easy if you're in Alexandria Kaiser
cortezes position isn't it this is like
somebody moving along the line at a
buffet you know filling his plate with
chicken wings and macaroni and cheese
saying talking about the the the power
of a hunger strike saying that you know
people should really go on a hunger
strike over this it's very easy to say
by the way working for a living earning
an income that is liberating that is
there is dignity in that there are a lot
of people who want to work for a living
I know that might be shocking to
somebody like Alexandra o kaiser Cortese
but there are people who want to do that
who would there are people who would
much prefer to work for a living than to
be handed money from the government
it's amazing to me all these people that
say well it's okay you could take away
someone's livelihood their job their
business whatever because the
government's giving them checks anyway
well first of all there are a lot of
people who need the checks are who
aren't getting them and many of the
people who are getting the checks it's
not nearly enough $1,200 isn't enough to
subsidize the light the lives of you
know of entire families for weeks on end
just it's not even close to enough but
even if it was enough it tells me
something about you if you think that
that's an even trade
you know it take for example a man who's
working and has a job he's proud of his
job he's worked to get to the position
that he is he's honed his craft and he's
supporting his family's proud that he's
supporting his family and then you come
in and you take all that from him and
you hand them a check from the
government and you say see it's I no
harm no foul that just tells me
something about you that you don't
understand why a man may much prefer to
go to work and earn that money and bring
it back to his family to feed his kids
and support his family if you don't
understand that that's again that just
tells me something about your character
number three leftists are having a ball
today passing along sharing I've seen
his photo all over the place it's a
photo from an anti lockdown protest in
Tennessee so take a look at edit here
it's as you can see somebody at a
protest holding a sign that says
sacrifice the week and people are
sharing this and saying you see these
anti lockdown people are a bunch of
murderous nihilistic suicidal lunatics
this proves it this proves my point and
the media of course has put this photo
front and center in their articles about
the pro about all the lockdown protests
they take this photo and of course this
photo now is representative of the
entire movement the people taking this
sign at face value I'm not sure exactly
what the most charitable interpretation
of them is because either they are
extremely extremely stupid and they
really think that this is a genuine
protester who really feels this way or
they know better but they're pretending
and then they're liars so I'm not sure
either they're extremely dumb or they're
liars or maybe a combination of the two
obviously obviously this is a troll who
made that sign to parody and discredit
the movement which is not some crazy
conspiracy theory he doesn't require a
conspiracy it just requires one dude to
make a sign and go hold it on the
sidewalk okay that's it and it's very
that this is not someone who is actually
a friend of the anti lockdown position
pretty good rule of thumb here if you
see somebody at a protest holding a sign
that happens coincidentally conveniently
to helpfully vindicate the most absurd
caricature of the movement that is that
is you know presented by the other side
well that's a very good indication that
the person doesn't actually support the
movement you know if you're looking at
pictures of a protest and you it's a
protest that you disagree with and you
see one sign that just happens to fit
right in to your cartoonish view of this
of this movement you disagree with well
if your person of intellectual integrity
you're gonna stop for a minute and say
yeah I don't know this is a little bit
it's a little bit too good to be true
and we know that that this is something
people are doing you remember that fake
flyer for a fake rally in New York
telling sick people to come out that was
totally fake it was not something was
not a rally that was it wasn't even a
real rally at all nobody showed up to it
so we know that people are doing this
and it's pretty clear to me this is an
example now of course look there's a
there's like a 1% chance I suppose that
that is a that's a genuine protester who
is who's insane so that could be a real
crazy person but it's like a 1% chance
99% chance or more that that of course
is just a troll another dead giveaway if
the sign itself is not a giveaway the
fact that he's wearing a disguise he's
wearing a mask and sunglasses he doesn't
want to he doesn't want to be seen on
camera you notice a lot of the other
protesters aren't wearing masks that's
one of the complaints that the anti
protest people have is that these guys
are showing up at the rallies not
wearing masks the one guy who comes with
the mask also sunglasses happens to be
holding this crazy sign what does that
tell you now if you're wondering why
people are actually protesting here's a
report from the local ABC affiliate and
I think this give
a better a better view of it watch this
the signs say it all these Tennesseans
want governor Lee to open up the state
especially small businesses now Gregg
and Zeta Sorrell have both been out of
work for several weeks because of co bid
19 restrictions I'm brave enough to go
to work and I'm brave enough to you know
be near my fellow humans and I hate that
we have to see each other as a disease
now I appreciate people who want to you
know quarantine and who can afford to do
it and you know who can make that that
sacrifice and do that that's great I
appreciate it I think you're free to do
it I should be free to not do it
Adrian hich owns a hair salon in
Hendersonville she says the state hasn't
helped her with unemployment and she
didn't get a Small Business
Administration loan before the funding
ran out we have no problem being shut
down but we can't afford to stay shut
down if we don't have some kind of an
income coming in state representative
Bruce griffey recently sent a letter to
Governor Lee aging him to open the
economy immediately he says will face
dire consequences if that doesn't happen
he also says it's not fair that big-box
stores like Lowe's in the Home Depot get
to stay open while so many small
businesses had to close any of the
people at today's rally weren't wearing
face masks or socially distancing from
others okay now those people seem like
suicidal nihilist to you is the same
protested the guy with the sacrifice the
week sign was at but what do you think
the people that were interviewed know
that they seem like perfectly reasonable
individuals even saying they're saying
look I I think it's great to quarantine
if you want to do that I'm not saying
you shouldn't but I need to work to feed
my family that's it that's a reasonable
position and that's how most anti
lockdown people feel none of them are
saying sacrifice the weak because that's
the cartoon of the movement that people
on the other side have drawn number four
speaking of why people are protesting
the new jobless numbers are in about
four and a half million additional
people applied for unemployment last
week that
brings our total to almost 27 million
and as I always remind you that's just
the tip of the iceberg
doesn't count many millions of other
unemployed people but now we're at 27
million by next week it's gonna be 30
million more than 30 million we're
looking at in fact right now it's
probably more than 30 million but the
numbers don't come out until a week
later number 5 here's a refreshing
change of pace rather than you know
rather than talking about the
coronavirus let's talk about a different
disease now change it up a little bit
Chipotle has agreed to pay a twenty five
million dollar fine which apparently is
a record because it served tainted food
that sickened over a thousand people but
the fun thing is like I said this is not
the corona virus this was actually well
as various things ecoli food poisoning a
lot of intestinal type stuff so we're
given that we're giving the lungs a
break and we're moving on to a disease
lower down in the body you know honestly
I don't blame Chipotle for this this is
on the customers because and most people
I thought knew this when you go to
Chipotle and I love Chipotle and I'll
keep going to Chipotle but you have to
tell them to hold the e.coli because
otherwise how are they supposed to know
you don't want it so I always say you
know let me get the burrito pinto beans
chicken hot sauce you know the hot salsa
guac corn cheese lettuce no sour cream
because putting a dairy product on a
burrito is disgusting who does that well
cheese is a dairy product but you know
it doesn't that doesn't count but then
you have to say no e.coli please hold
the e.coli now on occasion I'll say can
you just sprinkle a dash of food
poisoning just a little bit not too much
but generally I tell the Holden you have
to be able to do that all right let's go
to your daily cancellation I've been
trying to put off playing this video
because it's so disturbing and grotesque
but we just talked about food poisoning
so I think it kind of it kind of works
there's a natural transition here if you
haven't seen this video I have to warn
you and I mean this sincerely it's a
serious thing not trying to be funny
but this is this video it may be the
most disturbing and grotesque thing that
I have ever seen on the internet which
of course is saying quite a lot so if
you have kids with you right now as
you're watching this and I would say
maybe wait
they're in bed later come back and watch
it probably not appropriate for them but
here it is mayonnaise
we need cheese let's get out all right
first of all two pieces of bread put
them out on the plate
open up the viennese make sure you get
plenty on both sides
next comes the important part the twin
and my personal preference is chicken
let's see you gotta make sure you
distribute this evenly across the bread
in a way that's even inappropriate again
if you're having trouble keeping up you
can pause because the place where the
turn is very important
next your favorite cheese for me medium
cheddar slice man put this on the other
side of the bread put it in you need
heating device I'm learning with the MVP
5 and my old favors usually about 30
seconds
shocking disturbing grotesque that was
Senator Mark Warner of Virginia I
believe giving a tutorial on how to make
a tuna milk but instead of showing us
how to make a tuna melt he really showed
us how to commit a crime against
humanity I don't even know where to
begin
here first of all what sort of demented
psycho lunatic dumps the tuna right on
the bread without mixing it first not
only that but he doesn't even drain it
so that tuna is leaked the tuna water is
leaking all over the bread making it
soggy and then he puts about 47
tablespoons of mayo all over the bread
so that there's more mayo than tuna and
then he puts the whole damn thing Mayo
bread tuna
the microwave for 30 seconds and
remember the Mayo is not mixed with the
tuna so it's gonna be it's gonna come
out skull dick thing about Mayo for 30
seconds in the microwave that's a long
time
I mean Mayo for any amount of time in
the microwave is too much but 30 seconds
it's gonna come out scalding hot you
have this scalding hot magma like mayo
dripping all over pungent hot tuna
encased in soggy warm tuna water soaked
bread and dripping with cheese my God in
heaven deliver us from evil in Jesus
name have mercy and just think this man
was elected to political office
he's a deranged nihilist who likes to
eat soggy warm fish flavored bread and
yet somehow this maniac was elected the
United States Senator which just goes to
show and I've been saying this for years
you know I've been saying that I've said
it so many times one of the first
questions that they should ask at a
debate is is the first question that you
pose to candidates is is how do you
prepare your tuna sandwiches because you
could tell so much about someone based
on that and I also recommend on a first
date that should be your first question
as well so Mark Warner is cancelled now
we're gonna move on we're gonna do a
couple emails but before we do you know
we've been telling you about this double
tumblr promo and if you haven't had a
chance yet
you got to become a daily wire insider
plus or all-access member because when
you do you get not one but two of the
magnet and magnificent glorious
beautiful inspiring life-changing
tumblers and not only that begin many
other benefits as well you get an
ad-free website experience access to our
all to our live broadcast show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show access to the mailbag and now
exclusive election insight op-eds as
well from ben shapiro delaware members
also get to ask us questions during
backstage which we've as I said we have
one last night and you get to
participate in our new all-access live
hangout shows which are a lot of fun as
well so again that's to leftist tiers
tumblers not just one but two when you
become a daily wire insider plus are all
ex
member and you get 10% off with coupon
code Walsh Jess had a head on over to
daily wired.com slash subscribe okay
let's see this is from Justin says hi
Matt I disagree with your previous
assertions regarding personality tests
particularly the myers-briggs I have
taken this test many times over the
course of almost a decade and have
gotten the same result every time you
argued that these tests are merely a
reflection of the kind of person you
wish you were not who you actually are
while this while aspirational
personality traits may influence some
people when taking the test many people
take the test honestly to get deeper
insights into just what their
personality is but also why they are the
way they are I wish I was more
extroverted and less moody but I still
get classified as an introvert with an
inclination for feeling for feeling
overthinking every time the various
descriptions and explanations of my
personality type have also been
consistently accurate not just to me but
others who know me this includes both
positives and negatives of my
personality type okay well but this just
and just this just raises the quite no I
still think the problem of personality
test is that in many cases people are
putting in now you may be very honest
about it but I think you're probably
exception I think most people put in the
personality traits that they wish they
exhibited part of that is a lack of
self-awareness so it's it's they don't
do it on purpose but to take a
personality test honestly here's the
issue to take a personality test and get
a accurate result requires
self-awareness okay but if you have
self-awareness then you already know
you're aware of yourself you already
know what kind of personality you have
so what's the point of the test you've
said you've taken it multiple times and
if you get the same result why do you
keep taking the test
you obviously know who you are so I
don't understand why do you want to take
a test so that the test can tell you
what sort of person you are when you
already know it either you don't already
know what kind of person you are so you
lack self-awareness so the test isn't
gonna work because they're not gonna be
answering the questions honestly or at
least accurately or you do you do have
self-awareness so you already know
what's the point I just I don't get it
just look in a mirror it just seems a
lot more a fish
if you want to know what you're all
about this is from Jennifer I sent you
this comment several months ago and feel
I must now give you personal anecdotes
of weird homeschool kids example one
there was a guy who I went to college
with who was homeschooled through middle
school his hair was unkempt and he would
sit on top of the fridge in the Union to
do his homework is this normal
no you may think this is cruel but he
dressed like he was raised in a barn no
sense of style whatsoever example two
there was another guy who I also went to
college with who was home-schooled
through middle school as well he often
made inappropriate penis jokes that
apparently were super funny to his
brother at home but certainly were not
in a co-ed environment oh yeah because
he never kids in public school would
never make jokes like that never
happened it's not like every single
bathroom stall you walk into what a
public school is decorated with pictures
of Jen tail you know that's all it's the
thing only home schoolers would do as
she goes on these two were homeschooled
and we're the weirdest people I met in
college I guarantee they would have
acted more socially acceptable had they
gone to public / private school I have
more examples but I think these are
sufficient for now I guarantee there are
many other who have similar stories you
may disagree but there's a stereotype
for a reason well Jennifer hey this just
I assumed you were not homeschooled
because of your you know view of home
schoolers so this just tells me really I
mean it just tells me something about
you and and maybe about public school or
especially because it's amazing to me I
think I've used that phrase about five
times during the show it's amazing to me
I'm amazed far too often when in fact
actually none of the things I've said
are amazing actually amazed me so I
should probably anyway this argument
it's not even an argument but any time
we talk about home honor I've talked
about homeschooling this is the number
one response that I hear it's people
giving anecdotes about we quote unquote
weird home schoolers they know so a few
problems with that number one the first
guy you mentioned okay so you didn't
like his uh his style you know like the
kind of clothes he wore and he didn't
like where where he sat when he did his
homework well I would say that's that's
it's that just reflects your own
superficiality
if I you know if you don't if you don't
like the way someone dresses and you
judge them based on that now if you want
me to admit our our home schoolers less
likely to be caught up on all the latest
fashions I would say probably ok it's
also not the year 1840 - I mean home
schoolers are still gonna be plugged in
in a literal sense to the culture and
they're out they have friends they're
out and you know they're not they're not
it's not it's not like the village them
night Shyamalan movie where you know
they're in a some village in the in the
woods and we're pretending it's 1840 -
no in most cases they're out in society
they they're they have friends they know
what people are wearing and dressing and
now they're talking and everything else
but are they because they're not
immersed in that culture are they a
little bit less likely to be up on the
fads yeah but so what if that's if
that's the kind of weird you're talking
about that's good to have a kid who
doesn't care as much about being caught
up on trends what's the advantage of
being caught up on trends does it make
you a better person does it make you a
more interesting person does it that you
look exactly like everybody else you're
wearing the same name brands oh that's a
that's really interesting isn't it it
doesn't make you a better person doesn't
make you a new more interesting person
doesn't make you a better adjusted
person it's not a reflection of your
character so who cares the fact that you
care just tells me that you're
superficial which is not a good
reflection of public school but of
course the other problem is that
anecdotes don't prove anything and for
every anecdote you can give me of a
quote-unquote weird home schooler I can
give you ten anecdotes of weird public
schoolers so we could go back and forth
with anecdotes all day long
and you want to talk about weird you
want how about weird how about weird how
about how about all the school shooters
that show up at public schools okay
those are those some we're pretty weird
people aren't they you don't have that
problem at home school do you so if you
really want to get into the anecdotes we
can do that but I don't think you want
to play that game because we could start
with with the school shooters and we can
work our way down from there all right I
think and here's the third thing most of
the time when people talk about
weird homeschoolers what they really
mean and there are some legitimately
genuinely weird homeschoolers okay it
like weird in a negative sense that does
exist I'll fully admit there are weird
people in the world they exist they're
out there some of them are going to end
up in home school it's it's inevitable
although I would argue they're a lot
more than the public school but I think
often when someone says home schoolers
are weird what they really mean is that
they're weird in the sense that they
don't act like other kids act in modern
in our modern culture and I would say
that is weird in a very good way I hope
my kids are weird that way I don't want
my kids acting like every other kid okay
I I want my kids to be mature to be to
be able to hold a conversation to not be
dependent all the time on being glued to
their phone and electronics and so on to
be able to talk about something other
than video games and TV okay if that's
what you mean by weird and I think often
times that is what people mean by weird
great awesome that that's one of the
best arguments for homeschool so that my
kids can be that kind of weirdo it's
also just kind of strange that so many
parents seem to want their kids to be
just like all the other kids why would
that be your aspiration for your kid
for your kid to act like every other
[ __ ] out there is that really your ass
bridge is that really what you want for
them but thanks for the email Jennifer
we will leave it there thanks for
watching everybody
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there